right hello everyone my name is Steven
Hoover and I'm here from civis analytics
service analytics offers a cloud-based
data science platform that helps data
scientists to to scale their data
accelerate their workflows schedule and
share and I'm going to be talking about
recently I led an effort to replace the
machine learning backend in that
platform with the new machine learning
backend based around scikit-learn and
this presentation is about the how and
the why of that since you're here at PI
data you probably care about machine
learning already
but organizations everywhere are finding
that it's a good idea to use the data
that they have to make better decisions
and sometimes you can use your laptop
for this but sometimes you can't
sometimes your datasets are too large
sometimes you don't want your data in
your work to be trapped on your own
machine and sometimes you just have
better things to do with your laptop
than to leave it sitting open all night
fitting a random forest so you can get
around this by going to a cloud-based
infrastructure in the cloud you have
access to larger databases more
resources more and more persistent
compute and a shared environment so that
you can collaborate with other people
the sieve a state of science platform
started as a way for us to accelerate
our own consulting work the original
machine learning capabilities were fit
to what we need to do at the time we
were doing a lot of work in sequel so it
needs to interface well with sequel
database and we're doing a lot of
feature engineering there and it ended
up being that we were doing mostly
linear models as we grew we develop more
sophisticated workflows and especially
as we opened up the platform to other
clients we found that we need something
more powerful more sophisticated and
more flexible and that's why we decided
to replace the machine learning
capabilities with new ones based
entirely around scikit-learn or rather
the scikit-learn api more specifically
why scikit-learn
so scikit-learn is a standard in python
machine learning
but he knows that we don't want to force
people to learn new tools and because
it's a standard there's also there's a
lot of tooling built up around it
already it's flexible and extensible if
there's something that's not available
for scikit-learn then you can make it
yourself and in fact we've we've made
our own extension in several places I'm
sure many of you have as well the reason
you can do that is because there's a
standard interface there's a way that
all of the code objects in scikit-learn
interact with each other and what I'm
talking about there is the API so I
can't learn it has a very well-defined
rigid API rigid in a good way I'd say
because it's so well defined you can fit
pieces together the core of that is fit
you want to learn from your data you
call fit you want to use those learnings
on new data you can call predict or
transform depending on what it is and
and you your model is not just one piece
your model is not just your classifier
your model includes all of your feature
extraction steps all of your your
missing value imputations all of that
and so I could learn provides an
abstraction so that you can wrap that
all together into a single object
there's multiple higher level
abstractions one of the more powerful
ones is this pipeline the pipeline lets
you wrap up several steps so that's all
so that all looks like a single model
you can use it as one piece you can
store it and and take it back out as one
piece fits predict by doing this by
using these abstractions you can create
your own tools for example at civis
we've created an open source library
called muffin which wraps tensorflow
tensorflow itself isn't scikit-learn
compatible but we put that inside
wrappers which are which mean that by
making our machine learning backend
around the scikit-learn api we get deep
learning for free you know it's it's
part of the part of the psyche you learn
API now that's the software what kind of
hardware are we working with we we don't
want to do a lot of extra re-engineering
of our infrastructure so we want to work
with what we have available already the
the civis data science platform is going
to handle all of user entry
for us there's an API there's a
graphical user interface it's handling
security its handling AWS resource
management the pieces of AWS
infrastructure that we have to work with
for this are three main pieces one is
redshift
redshift is a massively parallel
processing database this is what we use
our primary data store
we have s3 available for staging data
and we use ec2 for arbitrary computation
in fact we can launch more ec2 instances
on demand we use docker containers to
make sure that the environment that we
have there is reproducible you don't
just say run this job you say run this
job in this docker container and you
know it's going to run for sure because
you know what environment it's running
in that's been really helpful for us
there's two kinds of scaling that I want
to address in this talk today one kind
of scaling is this horizontal scaling
this may seem trivial but I think it's a
really important point if you if you
want to train your model and check over
several different hyper parameters maybe
you have 15 20 50 different hyper
parameter combinations you want to check
you want to do that all at once not in
serial or often we run into situations
where we want to simultaneously train
models on a dozen different dependent
variables again that's something that
you want to do in parallel not in serial
the other kind of data scaling that I
want the other kind of scaling that I
want to discuss is data and that's what
we use redshift and s3 for redshift is a
petabyte scale database we don't
generally use petabyte scale individual
tables but the tables that we use are
still big enough that they're not going
to all fit inside a single you see 2's
memory at once requirements we have to
be able to use data from redshift as I
said it's a primary data store in
particular we want to be able to use
large-scale data from redshift when I
say big here what I mean is data that
doesn't necessarily fit into RAM on a
single machine to make things a little
bit easier for this first iteration of
our modeling tool that we're only using
data large data for predictions
most of our use cases involve data that
fits in memory for training but data
that doesn't fit in memory for
predictions so that's what I'm going to
focus on why can't you just go ahead and
call fit on your secular an object so
you've got your pipeline why not just
fit X and why they have to be numpy
arrays but we don't have numpy arrays we
have a large table and redshift so
unfortunately we can't just put our
scikit-learn code into redshift redshift
does it work that way we have to pull
the data out redshift favorite way of
unloading data by far the fastest and
the easiest is to dump everything into a
CSV so we dump it into a CSV move that
into s3 from s3 we copy it into ec2 use
pandas to read that in then going
through a CSV you can lose type
information which is not so great a
particular corner case which is not so
cornered because we run into it all the
time is that you have a column which is
a string but it looks like an integer
maybe one two three accepted strings
which is all fine and good until row
number twenty 2338
has a one two three instead of one two
three and if you do your type inference
from the first few rows you'll get an
error not fun so you can retype
information from redshift we don't use
the type information directly we cast it
casting all numerical values to float
32s for a couple of reasons one is that
you don't need 64 bit precision for this
kind of work and you save a lot of RAM
by cutting that in half the other is
that you need homogeneous data types for
an umpire is anyway
and finally the pandas treats missing
values as numpy na ends and a ends our
float types and that means that if your
integer column has or might ever have a
missing value in it you need to be
treating it as a float value right and
finally we have to know which of those
columns are for our features which of
those columns are target's for that you
have to ask the user ask the user to
point out which columns are which and
pull those out and arrange them into
arrays
next problem is that some of these
features might be strings no
scikit-learn doesn't deal with strings
natively so you have to convert your
strings into numeric types pandas has a
get dummy's function which is nice when
you're doing data exploration but
there's a couple problems with that one
is that it's there's no obvious way to
use that to reproduce the same one-hot
encoding on a future data set another
problem is that the it has excessive RAM
use and so we wrote our own one hot
encoding with repeated applications of a
secular and label encoder that's worked
out really well for us
then what about prediction so first step
for prediction is that you have to get
the data into you have to get the data
into your ec2 instance same as before
new wrinkle is that you need to make
sure that your features are in the same
order as they were for training you you
have an unlabeled array when you're
working in scikit-learn and if you
happen to transpose some columns then
your predictions are no longer going to
be relevant or correct so that you store
metadata you record what order the
feature what over the columns were when
you did your training and you can
reproduce that for prediction another
problem is that we want to be able to
upgrade this code every once in a while
we want to be able to make changes but
we also want to make sure that the
models you train today you can make
predictions with tomorrow next week or
next year and for that we wrap
everything inside a docker container and
we use semantic versioning with semantic
versioning that's your three point
version numbers one point two point
three the first version the first number
increases whenever you have API breaking
changes for us there's two kinds of API
breaking changes one is if the user
something the user is inputting changes
what it does that's obviously API
breaking another important kind of API
breaking is if your training job no
longer produces your prediction job no
longer works with the outputs of the
previous versions training job that is
also an API breaking change that we want
to record we also want users to be aware
of new releases new
new feature additions if we change the
way that we're doing modeling for
example maybe it's not an API breaking
change but it might change at least
subtly there are kinds of results that
you get out of your your pipeline and we
don't want automated workflows to change
out from under people so that's
something they have to opt into
and finally bug fix versions those don't
change any existing functionality we do
produce for archival purposes docker
containers with the full major/minor
micro versions eggs but in production we
run docker containers that are tagged
with major and minor versions only and
we rewrite those with new versions
whenever we have bug fixes that lets us
transparently deploy any fixes into
production finally going back to scaling
maybe your data sets are really really
big fortunately prediction is an
embarrassingly parallel task you can
take your data and divide it up you
don't care about looking at row number
five when you're making predictions with
row number 20 and redshift gives you the
fastest way to export data from redshift
actually gives you multiple CSVs in fact
it gives you CSVs with a maximum size of
6.2 gigabytes and that is not too large
as to be unwieldy so we take those CSVs
and we move them into it into our dr
containers and run prediction tasks on
each of those separately when you run
the training you serialize your model
take your your scikit-learn
pipeline after it's been trained store
it and upload it to s3 separately upload
a JSON blob of metadata when you're
running predictions you pull those back
down pull those into the docker
containers unpack them and run them on
each CSV and for even better memory use
purposes we don't have to read the
entire CSV into memory at once it's easy
to iterate over just chunks of that CSV
so we read in a few thousand rows at a
time make predictions write the
predictions out read in the next few
thousand rows make predictions append
that so forth and so on until you've
gone through the entire CSV
some things you need to remember if
you're doing something like this the
first is that bandwidth is not infinite
especially if you're moving large
amounts of data around that takes time
so compression is your friend
make sure to compress everything the
next problem is that every API call
every Network communication that you
make take some amount of time and you
want to minimize that time you want to
minimize the number of network
communications that you make and
possibly even more important reason to
minimize the number of network
communications that you make is that
you're going to have failures if you're
running predictions on hundreds of
chunks of data at once then the chance
that at least one of those is going to
hit a 500 error sometime is going to
approach one so you want to first
minimize the number of times that you
have to communicate over the network
second you want to make sure that you
are wrapping all of those network
communications and retries all right now
a little bit about the tooling that we
use Java web is a library in Python that
facilitates parallel processing I'll
give a quick call out to the
serialization functionality if you
pickle and python pickling is is
inefficient for pickling for storing
numpy arrays job lid is has a pickling
plus functionality it will pickle
objects unless they are numpy arrays in
which case it uses numpy save it's much
more efficient you should use that if
you're moving data around numpy sorry
job Lib also provides parallel
processing capabilities parallel
processing with job Lib looks like this
you take the function that you want to
parallel eyes you wrap it in this
delayed decorator and then you feed an
iterator of calls to this delayed
function into the parallel class job Lib
provides an easy way for you to swap out
the backend that you're using for this
these predictions here multi-processing
is the default job live back-end and
here I'm specifying that explicitly
multi-processing
means using pythons built-in
multi-processing
library to
two parallel lies over different Python
processes job live also has a threading
back-end if you don't care about the Gil
but importantly job live lets you write
your own custom backends we've done this
for the civis platform and you can use
this syntax which is pretty easy to
parallelize your code in the cloud you
run this register parallel back-end
function from from job Lib and this
tells job Lib to run lu2 to use the
civis back-end you call this function
here I tell it to use service back in
and now this square root function is
parallelized in the cloud which is nice
and all but maybe a little boring more
interestingly scikit-learn internally
uses job Lib to parallelize its code and
this this is almost entirely pure
scikit-learn code the one bit that i've
added is now i'm i'm registering this
new parallel back-end civis and by
running inside the with parallel
back-end service context this grid
search is now parallelized on AWS using
a different ec2 instance for each node
into the hyper parameter search if you
want to make your own custom job live
back-end the first thing you do is you
subclass this parallel back end based on
parallel back-end base abstract class
when you do this there's two methods you
need to override one is effective number
of jobs that's pretty simple how many
jobs can this run the time the other is
apply async apply async needs to take a
function as input and it needs to return
a return immediately with a delayed
result net result is the other thing
that you need to write oh sorry optional
but highly recommended is this abort
everything method if job Lib runs into
an error in one of the sub jobs that
it's processing it will stop immediately
and print an error message to screen for
the user it will assume that if one job
fails all of them fail and if you
provide an abort everything method on
your back-end then job will call that
for you maybe this doesn't matter quite
so much if you're running in different
processes on your own machine but if you
launched a hundred job
subs in the cloud and one of them fails
you don't want to leave the other 99
running you'd be nice to shut those down
and free up those resources so that you
don't wait for them all to finish when
you're going to be ignoring the results
anyway so abort everything is useful
thing to do the result class your reply
async method needs to output one of
these results and it's it doesn't have
to be a subclass of anything it's duck
typed the thing that it quacks like is a
standard library async result object
slight differences you need to take a
callback function in the init Java web
uses these callback functions so that it
can know when an individual process is
finished and when it can add new
processes to when it can start working
on new new chunks of work the other
thing you need to implement is this get
method get' needs to be blocking you
call get and it should return the result
of the the chunk of work that it was
assigned it also needs to call this
callback function optional but nice to
use is the transportable exception if
you if you have an error in your remote
job if you can wrap that in a
transportable exception and send it back
to job Lib then job Lib will be able to
display the trace back on the screen
give more information to the user about
what went wrong it's difficult enough
debugging errors and distributed
computing you want to make this as easy
on yourself as possible so I recommend
using the transportable exception the
way we've implemented this we already
had an implementation of the standard
library executor module or executor
executor class which launched jobs in
the service platform and the executor is
in the concurrent futures module submit
returns a future if you are familiar
with the future abstraction that's
definitely worth taking a look at I find
that it's really a convenient way to do
asynchronous computation in particular
for this use the the future
lets us retry jobs pretty easily when
the remote job is complete then it will
set it state on the future object if
it's successful all well and good if it
fails it's going to set
exception if you can we intercept
attempts to set that exception and if
their user has requested retries then we
automatically retry and that
transparently and immediately retries
jobs as soon as they fail the other
thing that we have in a to make the job
live back-end work is a wrapper function
when we're sending data out to be to run
in the service platform we packed that
function up and store it nest 3 when we
launch the remote job we're calling this
wrapper function the wrapper function
downloads the function from s3 it
unpacks it runs it and then packages up
the results or the exception if there
was an error sends it back to s3 and
finally instead of downloading results
inside the results the result objects
get method we use it as a user callback
on this future object to download the
results as soon as the object is done as
soon as the remote computing is done and
called jobless callback and finally this
is all open sourced if you go to our
github repo service Python that's our
API client you can see the job live
implementation it's on master branch
right now it will be in an upcoming
release hopefully a next week or two
right
some things to remember when you're
doing this make sure the remote
environment can execute your code this
is pretty important if your remote
environment is a docker container on ec2
whatever you pickle that code needs to
be available in your doctor environment
Python doesn't tickle the code
underlying the functions it pickles the
the reference to the code so the code
itself has to be available in your
remote environment installed there the
reason I talked about calling
downloading results as a callback on the
future is that result git will call your
results one that job Lib calls get one
the time in order on all of your chunks
of work if you wait until you call get
on your results before you tell job Lib
that it's done what we were seeing was
that we
you would we'd have maybe 20 things to
do and assign 10 workers to it we would
use the first 10 jobs we're all complete
before we would start the next set of 10
jobs what you want to do is you want to
keep everything working continuously
that was because we even though the jobs
already completed job live didn't know
until we'd gotten to the place where we
actually called get on that chunk of
work so that was solved with with the
callbacks for the futures and make sure
to retry when you're downloading results
it's really annoying to have a job a
remote job succeed but then have your
entire job crash because you ran into a
500 error when you tried to download the
results from s3 that's happened to me
more than once
and finally we make extensive use of the
standard library logging module it's
extremely helpful job Lib uses print
statements so you want to capture those
and redirect them into your logger and
using the job web back-end this is what
the implementation of parallel scoring
inside the civis machine learning
back-end looks like so we like I was
showing you before we register back-end
I think the may be the new thing here is
the infer backend and for a back-end
factory function if you're running
inside the service platform we're able
to introspect our environment so that we
can make sure that we're reproducing
that on the remote worker that solves a
problem of making sure that all of the
local code is available there right and
this then is the modeling interface for
civis modeling tool service ml once
everything is finally finished you can
define your scikit-learn what you can
define your model if I was at
scikit-learn compatible register it with
a civis platform use data that's either
local or possibly coming from from a
redshift table and then your train call
is non walking it returns a future you
can do whatever other work you want to
do in the meantime
maybe that's launching dozens of other
models
and then your predict function you can
run predictions on large-scale data and
it will complete in linear time because
the Bauman's you have enough
computational resources available sorry
a constant time as long as you have
enough computational resources available
and it's not just objects from the
scikit-learn standard library of course
it's like you learned core library
anything that's scikit-learn compatible
for example XG boost the Python XG boost
library is follows the scikit-learn API
so you can use XG boost models just as
easily as you can use anything else
right and so that's a little bit about
our implementation thank you for
listening and happy to take questions
[Applause]
okay the question was how do we compare
this to using spark to do machine
learning on large data right yeah I
think sparks machine learning is great
if you have huge data sets to train on
there's very limited algorithms
available because a lot of algorithms
don't parallel eyes for training and
what we're doing here is we're trying to
take the code that you're available the
code that you're used to writing with
scikit-learn and let you run that in the
cloud
yeah so what if you install scikit-learn
in the individual nodes and you spark to
distribute the data yeah you should be
able to do that for scoring as well I
don't think I've I don't remember I
haven't explored that myself but yeah
that should be possible that's another
way to parallelize it instead of using
something like this job led back-end the
question is how do I compare desk with
job Lib
I think job led job would be news for
paralyzing individual functions I think
you could probably use bath bag or
something like that for this as well but
desk as I understand it as if you want
to do say split matrix large matrix
computations over many processes or many
nodes then you could use desk for
something like this I think for for this
particular task it would end up being
functionally equivalent the veining step
is not locking the composing room yeah
the question is the see the Train step
is non-blocking which is correct and
then the predict you have to wait until
the Train is complete of course and then
yeah the prediction step is is
non-blocking and it runs all the each
chunk of your large data is run in
parallel and then those are combined
back into a single table at the end so
the
irritation the question was if you can
predict my data set in s3 and just give
it the location yeah you can do that the
question is if job Lib is going to have
support for a more generalized text at
task execution system I'm not aware of
any plans for anything like that no desk
might be a better place to see something
like that happened at since desk is is
building interfaces to distributed
computing right the question is can I
talk about some of the design choices
behind using redshift for our storage
instead of other options such as RDS
redshift we found that redshift has been
a really good solution for very large
scale sequel queries if you're
interested in doing joins between large
data sets or group buys then redshift is
a good solution for that
I think RDS is a lot better for single
row operations but the use case that we
had originally was or large-scale data
and joins and column operations which
redshift is optimized for
like Diana home where I hardly know
around or the to the United States
entirely
how large the question is how you decide
how many nodes this runs on yeah the the
user has to specify how many jobs that
they're going to let the system use and
you know that's that's a maximum number
if it doesn't if it can't paralyze or
quite that many won't use quite that
many but you want to you want to avoid
hogging too many resources or using more
resources than then you expected I think
is one reason for that does the user get
to specify CPU and RAM resources for
each node for for training the user can
specify those resources for prediction
the user doesn't specify those because
the prediction resources are pretty well
bounded we're using small amounts of
data so you don't need much round
[Music]
so the question is how we looked into
reading directly from redshift into the
containers rather than going through CSV
is first without your question like a
comparison choice inside yes these are
not in a PC and you know interchange
format life for the person buffer and
see which one is work well like when we
people have a high bandwidth I like the
ones that often
okay yeah so you're asking if we've
explored different options for reading
for med shifts yeah yeah and the dumping
to CSVs is the fastest unfortunately red
shift is not optimized for row by row
reads it's as I was mentioning before
it's optimized for joins on columns it's
optimized for column operations and if
you want to pull the entire data set out
as a large block dumping it to CSV this
is actually the fastest way that we
found to do that it does sound weird I
admit yes yeah that's actually one of
the things that's next on our list
implement this story the question was if
we're planning on implementing the fit
partial method support for fit partial
and scikit-learn so that we can train
incrementally on potentially larger data
sets yeah that's one of the next things
aren't less to implement so the code
behind civis ml is not open source
mostly because I'm not sure I want to
take the time to clean it up and make it
look pretty enough but the the interface
in our in our API client is public and
the job web back-end code is is all
public now - yes it only works on AWS
yeah the it's it's all working through
the service platform which is based on
AWS if the service platform expanded to
use other clouds then this interface
would be the interface itself is
relatively agnostic to which cloud
resources it's using but the service
platform is based on AWS
all right so I think we are done
Oh
[Applause]